so then number two was about the
limitations of language and then do you
see
any similar limitations to
the language of mathematics to the
degree you can call it a language
as describing the universe
i i don't think mathematics uh
alone is sufficient
um
[Music]
uh
i mean i i listen and i read max tech
mark but nevertheless i think that
between mathematics and reality there is
a gap
um
i think mathematics is not out there
mathematics is a game we play fantastic
game play super useful
that we extract from from reality
but i think that
um
if i use case b if i think case by case
the mathematics that describe a pendulum
okay
which we learn at school when we study
you know the the differential equation
of the pendulum the solution sine or
cosine
it's beautiful mathematic but it's not a
pendulum
okay now you can say okay because
something is missing in a real pendulum
there's also this also this also this
but i think it it it stays like that i
mean you refine your model your
mathematical model
but
there's a jump between
uh there's always a jump between
mathematics and reality
and when you um
[Music]
when you do
you get to complicated theories like
current physical theory standard model
generativity
it's even stronger i mean these
equations need to be interpreted need to
be connected
to what we see and this connection
it's part of the story and it's even the
most interesting part of the story so to
say it's not sufficient to have
questions that i mean what does it mean
you have a question we have all space of
solutions
now max stigma could say okay that's
reality that's over all the reason we
just happen to be into one
um
but which one that's that's uh
that's the connection to reality
so this means that also mathematics has
the same problem that you are describing
i mean our
everyday language
might be inappropriate
to describe the world
we have to refine it we have to invent
the new new earth planet which include
the earth
uh but the same is true with mathematics
i mean the fact of writing a big
mathematical equations is completely
insufficient
unless we
uh
interpret
it's its ingredients and we connect it
to the world into our experience
so the
the indeterminacy of language that you
were referring to we have to struggle
with
uh with or without mathematics equally
and we have to live with it we
we should not
think that we can
you know get to the bottom of the story
and have a perfectly uh
logical perfect language description of
reality and everything is clarified
we're not there
completely not there by
by by zillions of miles
we are in a big mess in which we see a
complicated world we understand part of
it we understand some regularities of it
and we call this our physics
um
and this this takes me to the
the third question about the laws
yeah to the third question about the
laws
uh which you asked before um
i think that what laws are
as far as we know just uh irregularities
so
we
we see phenomena
we think that this is the way
uh
nature works so phenomenal not just with
respect to us the phenomena with respect
to
saturn when saturn when something hits
saturn this saturn it's it's hit by by a
meteorite like i'm hit by your voice
uh the world
it's it's it's it's this is a fact it's
a mixture of two things
of uh
uh contingent thing that we have no idea
how to predict
and predictable things
it's always been like that right i don't
know who will bring my phone next but i
know that tomorrow the sun will rise
i know exactly what time it will rise
okay
so there's a part of the world which is
incredibly easy to predict
i mean if i let this thing fall i know
it will go down and not up i can predict
it i can bet of it and i'm going to win
them it
so there's a huge part of the
world which is predictable and there's a
huge part of the world which is
unpredictable
so we organize that in our science and
physics in particular and we call the
predictable story the laws
that we found out okay this is what this
i mean we found some regularity very
very good very strongly i think we call
the laws
and we
have unpredictable part which we call
initial conditions or
uh you know and determination in quantum
mechanics we give other names
um to the fact that definitely the laws
are not sufficient to describe the world
right obviously because a single law has
many solutions we don't know which one
describes the world